Many people buy organic foods in the hope that they will feel healthy
And the likelihood of having a positive impact on the environment.
But are organic foods better for you and the environment in the first place?
For plants, the term organic means basically something that grows without the use of artificial fertilizers or pesticides
But this is a little tricky.
As you can see, many consumers buy organic materials to avoid all pesticides
But the fact is that organic farmers can still use insecticides and fungicides to prevent insects from destroying their crops
But provided they are not manufactured artificially.
There are more than 20 chemicals approved for organic use in the United States
Derived from natural sources such as plants
But studies have shown that some natural pesticides are actually more healthily and environmentally hazardous than those made by man.
Does not mean that all of them are bad but simply, "normal" does not always mean what is best for you or the environment.
Moreover, not all organic foods are fully organic.
If the label simply says "organic" it only contains 95% of the organic ingredients
If the label says "made of organic ingredients" on products such as bread, which may contain only 70%
While "containing organic ingredients" means that it may contain only 50%.
When the label says "100% Organic" it contains only organic ingredients.
In my opinion, the term "products of uninhibited animals" is also required
Only evidence of access to outdoor air for at least 5 minutes per day. Hey!
Interestingly, a synthesis analysis was conducted in 2012
Organic crop production was found to be 25 percent lower than the conventional ones
Despite very different variations between crop types.
For example, organic plant crops are usually 33% lower than conventional ones
Putting more pressure on the natural environment as long as more agricultural land is required.
However, organic legumes are only 5% lower
Since they are more efficient in absorbing nitrogen than organic fertilizers
Certainly, many organic farming practices such as cropping and mixed farming instead of using monoculture are better for soil and the environment.
But are they the best for you?
After analyzing 237 studies, the researchers concluded that organic fruits and vegetables are not more nutritious than traditionally grown food.
However, long-term studies of purely organic diets are difficult
Where most people eat a mixture of foods that contain inorganic ingredients.
In terms of short-term organic diets, they show higher levels of carotenoids, polyphenols,
Vitamin C and E, harmful cholesterol, antioxidant activity, signs of the immune system
The semen quality is higher than ever before. But the differences are clinically slim.
Children who have been placed in organic diets for 10 days have lower levels of organic phosphate in urine
Which are associated with higher concentrations with neurological problems
But both levels are orders of magnitude less than the amount needed to cause clinical damage
Just because the thing is organic, it does not make it better.
A bag of organic chips, for example, is still just a fried carbohydrate with very little nutritional value.
What is most surprising is that organic foods have a higher rate of being dangerous.
Although organic foods represent only 1% of farmland or area
But they account for 7% of food units recalled in 2015.
This year, for example, many flavors of CLIF plates were recalled from stores
Because organic sunflower seeds are potentially contaminated with listeria, a type of bacteria that kills hundreds in the United States each year.
Another study found coliform picteria in 10% of organic products, compared with 2% in traditional ones.
The truth is, eating organic foods can be good for you, and sometimes it is better for the environment.
But this is not important.
Production methods vary greatly for both organic and traditional foods, from farm to farm
Or from local farms to factory farms
And they are most likely a combination of methods that will lead to the greatest results for your health and the environment.
Organic and traditional foods can coexist and do not have to conflict with each other.
Anyone who tells you 100% sure that one way is better than the other is ignoring science.
When it comes to your health, they are really a combination of diet
Exercise and other different lifestyles and, of course, your genetic genes. Translation: team translate autrjim @